[MUSIC PLAYING]
How did you get to MIT?
I sort of had a long
path to getting here.
But I was a math
undergrad, and then
I actually was an economics
PhD for a couple of years
before deciding that
robotics was my true calling.
And then through a
fortunate series of events,
I ended up working on the
dark robotics challenge
and then ended up in Russ's lab.
I came to MIT after my
PhD at Boston University.
I did my PhD in robotics.
And before I did robotics,
I actually studied pigeons
and how they fly and
their dynamics of flights.
And so pigeons is the
way I got into robotics,
by looking at the
dynamics of them
and then wondering what could
happen if you could also
control those systems.
I finished my undergrad and
my masters back in 2011.
And then I was working
in industry for two years
at Johns Hopkins applied
physics lab, which was fun,
but it was more development.
And I really wanted
to do research.
I really wanted to
go back for my PhD.
So I worked on a few
research projects
and I applied for
my PhD a few places.
Got accepted to a few.
Got rejected from a lot.
And I wound up joining everybody
here at MIT for my PhD.
So I did my undergrad here, and
I really liked the community.
And especially I did a UROP,
the undergraduate research
with Daniella.
So I enjoyed that and
I was happy to stay on
as a grad student.
I won a scholarship
for my research
being one of the grand
challenges in engineering
and a PhD candidate at the
University of Cambridge.
And this year, I'm a Charles
M. Vest scholar at MIT.
I had mentioned to an
undergrad professor
that I was thinking about
maybe applying to PhD programs.
And she said, you
know, you should do it.
You should definitely do it.
You know, who cares
if you get it or not?
You should definitely try.
And I think that little push
that someone believing in me
was what I needed to get
over my fear and apply to MIT
and that is how I got in.
I came here as an undergrad and
I came to the admittance day
weekend.
And it was a lot different
than all of the other colleges
I had been to and everyone I
met was really interesting.
So I sort of just
decided to come.
And then once I was here, it
became really hard to leave.
So I'm still here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]